Missouri's governor is resisting calls
to resign after being accused of
assaulting and blackmailing a former
lover in his first interview since
facing those allegations Republican
governor Eric Greitens called the affair
consensual Greitens
admits to cheating on his wife before he
was elected Adriana Diaz is outside the
State Capitol in Jefferson City Missouri
with why federal officials may now be
investigating driana good morning good
morning the governor's kept a pretty low
profile since our st. Louis affiliate
KMOV reported that he had an
extramarital affair but in an interview
this weekend he did apologize though
showed no signs of stepping down this
was a consensual relationship more than
a week after facing accusations of
assault and blackmail during an
extramarital affair
Missouri governor Eric Greitens says
there's nothing to investigate
there was no hush money there was no
violence there was no threat of violence
there was no blackmail there was no
threat of blackmail there was no threat
of a photograph in blackmail those
things are absolutely false
Brighton's does admit he had an affair
with his former hairdresser recordings
obtained by CBS News appear to show the
unnamed woman detailing her alleged
encounter with governor Greitens to her
now ex-husband taped my hands to these
rings
[Music]
never mention my name governor I'm
asking you please resign Republican
state senator Rob Shaw wants Greitens to
step down but for additional reasons in
a Facebook post
shaf says he spoke to the FBI and
alleges Greitens received undisclosed
amounts of money from st. louis-based
pharmacy and healthcare corporations
including the company Express Scripts
last July kryten's issued an executive
order to award a no bid state contract
to the company that money is what's
referred to as dark money attorney Al
Watkins says the FBI also contacted and
interviewed his client Eli Carrabelle
last November he says karabell worked as
a volunteer for Greitens campaign and
was fired for raising questions about
anonymous political contributions it
appeared to my client that this money
was being used for personal purposes
that were designed to shut people up or
designed to exert influence over others
in a statement to CBS News Express
Scripts said it publicly disclosed its
donation to the governor it denied that
it was no bid and said that it received
no revenue from it the governor's office
also said there was nothing
inappropriate about the contract the
governor himself says he has not been
contacted by the FBI we reached out to
the FBI but they did not respond to our
request for comment Adriana Diaz thank
you for the PUC certainly thickens there
there's a lot of layers to that story I
just feel for mrs. Greitens though guys
they've gone through this very private
thing and now everybody's talking about
it and the story is not going away